a massive russian military convoy making
its way to keeve just miles away
from the capitol bill hemmer joins us
now from the big board with the latest
on russia's ominous push
amazing interview jesse good evening to
you that town of kharkiv where she's
coming from it's got 1.4 million people
jesse is like the size of san diego san
diego california has 1.4 million people
phoenix arizona is 1.6 mil that gives
you a sense
of the relative size of car keep right
here uh in the northeast and this this
town has just been pounded over the last
two days
uh jesse you just shown some video there
a moment ago these residential areas
just about every single one of those
buildings has some sort of shot either
going into it or coming out of it i mean
it's it's really remarkable stuff and
when all this clears at some point we're
going to get a better idea as to how
many civilians are put at risk here to
just watch that story what i did for you
jesse here this goes back to last
thursday it's february 24th um here in
the north of key if you're in the
northeast car key
down here in the nets region here and in
the south of crimea i just put the map
in motion a little bit day by day jesse
it's not significant it just sometimes
it's just very subtle but everything you
see in red is occupied by the russian
army so that's thursday uh this is
friday i know it's subtle but it's
significant when you're trying to
advance uh in a war like this and that
takes you to the 27th which was
yesterday of the 27th of february so
again the north the northeast in the
south here what we're seeing here at
advance just one more time here so this
is car keith the town i described a
moment ago it's about 20 miles just on
the near side of the border with russia
jesse we saw some satellite images the
other day that were taken on thursday
that showed this enormous military
staging area so
the russian military has the capacity to
go back and forth over the border now
and resupply if it wants to go ahead and
hit this town uh even more i'll take you
up to the north okay here we go capital
city of kiev right here this is the if i
can get this thing
going here so this is the border
of belarus and then right there it turns
into russia
so with daybreak earlier today one of
our big stories on america's newsroom
where the peace talks these well i
should call them truce talks uh that
were underway in belarus what came of
them it's a little uncertain but they
did agree to talk again uh near the
belarus polish border at some day to be
named
very soon here's the capital city down
here this is about 160 miles jesse
uh from the border here is about 90
miles and this is really i mean that's
been the push from the north for the
russian army to
to get on these roads and the convoy
pictures are just stunning you know
they're lined up two across for miles
sometimes three across for miles and
you wonder um
at what point if they're able to breach
this city
how much power
the russian army takes with it uh into
the capital city of kiev i'll take it
down here uh just in crimea and the
south uh this was really an uncontested
battle here there's an irrigation canal
that separates crimea from the rest of
ukraine
once that canal was breached by tanks
and trucks many days ago it was that was
pretty much
um
very little resistance on behalf of the
ukrainian army
and any of the reporting we're getting
here suggests that's the case that uh
the russian army was able to go right
across the border and really uh with the
border between crimea and uh and ukraine
and do what it wanted and go in any
direction at once and so i would just
say jesse in the days to come mary poll
is a town where you had 2 000 russian
marines
go ashore over the weekend just watch
this town it's a port city population
about 450 000.
and then if you're if if putin wants
he could eventually try and connect the
donbass region which is where we were
back in 2014
over to kershawn and into odessa just
watched that story in the days to come
but right now it um
it's going to be a long night in ukraine
jesse i'll see you later okay that land
bridge if that's put into place that's
just an incredible
tactical maneuver that's very very hard
to stop it would be established it'd be
a big russian bill that would be right
all right thanks so much bill sure hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else